замахнулися
бий
Порошенко
Порошенко я гублюся в догадках А навіщо
я їм сьогодні тут
знадобився ми на жаль маємо жорсткий
Антимайдан жорсткий реванж давай давай
давай
Це прямий ефір ви зказайте діяльност
народніх депутатів і журналістів Що ви
робите Володимире
Олександровича дорогій
мій вас ніхто не боїться
ні В цьому залі Ні на
вулиці
Вітаю вас дорогі порахабрати і
[оплески]
порахасестри перша але надзвичайно
важлива наша з
вами
[музика]
перемога
і це зробили
ви своєю незалежноністю ми з вами не
поступимося
ніколи це мій батько мені казав і навчив
мене любити Україну так і я її люблю це
мій батько сказав що ми
маємо боронити і захищати нашу
державуно слухайте
области Душу й тіло ми
положим за нашу
сду
ду і покажем
що ми
гра
поза
свого
роду Слава
Україні Слава Дякую ва
Марченко Україна з
тобоюже
[оплески]
Сашко погребицький з
нами
друзі Всіх вітаю Добрий день
[музика]
[оплески]
доб на додаток до російської агресії які
і відсічі і забезпечення збереження
України прибавилося епідемія
коронавіруса у нас станом на зараз
станом на сьогоднішній ранок захворіли
4500 люде порада
Міністерство охорони здоров'я закупити і
продовжити ту програму яку ми
започали не закупити ми будемо це робити
за
власний сьогоднішній день - Це справжній
дух країни допомагати тим хто цієї
допомоги зараз
потребує
я я ще раз кажу що ми вас ми не залишимо
[музика]
вас я
хочу команда яка дуже любить
[музика]
Україну якщо мене чує повар
128ї який в домі Генерала сварив
найсмачніший в моєму житті борщ
Закарпатський
[музика]
[оплески]
Слава
[музика]
[оплески]
Україні подобається тут ми мріємо що
крім того що Рі
[музика]
будуть відриті краматорсь і в Маріуполі
колинебудь теж Ми бачили такі посмішки
дітей влися в очі сині
тихоперши з
насні і слова палки
кохання він до неї
[музика]
промовля
що
[музика]
[оплески]
ручку
дкую
дякую Y